SPOOK
M- Hello!
Welcome
ooooOOOOoooo
It's halloween again!
Well, not again.
It's not- It-It's not halloween yet!
It's- umm...
It's another halloween celebration!
I gotta get my mask
(cue batman voice)It's halloween
ooooOOOOooo
Is that the ghost of my dead parents?!
My parents are dead
woooOOOOOOOOOOoooOOOooOO
T- AhahahAHHAA-
M-So
I'm Batman
He's...
*Silent judging of fashion sense*
T- I'm a cave...woman
M- Literally just a cavewoman
We have new costumes that we got
and um...
Y-yeah, he picked that one
T- I didn't pick it!
M- You picked it!
T- YOU picked it!
M- You PICKED it!
Mark: Ahh, whatever.
Tyler: I didn't order it!
M- OK, whatever, alright.
So TODAY
with our pumpkins, we're not gonna be -uh-cutting 'em open
We're gonna be EXPLODING them open
*crash noises with glass breaking*
*growling noises*
*high pitched scream*
*sirens*
Both-ooOOOooOOOOOOOOOoOOOooOOOooo
Ahahaha!
Hehehehe!
We're gonna be EX--PLODING them open by seeing
how many rubber bands it takes to blow up one of these.
T- And THEN..
M- No.
T- ..we have another method-
M- No!
SSHHH!!
T- That you have to wait to see.
That you have to wait to see.
Yeah, don't skip ahead.
Once again, if you skip ahead in the video and
see the surprise, we're gonna
MMMMmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm
mmmmmmmmm....
*smooch*
*magical chime*
That'll happen.
T- He's Batman.
M- We're not going to time ourselves cause' we'll just...
It's whoever gets it first. Right?
Right.
Right!
Get it down
Geez!
My nipple is gonna' pop out every time I put a rubber band around it.
That's OK.
Just added entertainment
But that's not the special surprise!
If you fast forward and saw that
Pssh
You're a loser
Alright
I guess go
*laughter*
I gotta'... I gotta' like get rid of the stem
Come on and be a man, Batman!
*grunting "I'm Batman...I'm Batman!*
Wait! We never drew faces!
What do I gotta' stop?!
Geeezz
My guy's gonna be screaming.
There we go, good enough.
I feel like mine has gotten skinnier ( ͡° ʖ̯ ͡°)
I feel like mine hasn't done
jack
SHIT!!!
*intense grunting*
Mark: Frickin frick
*flick to the penis*
*laughter*
Did it getcha in the
NUTS?!
[Painful] Yes..
Okay, so ignore the fact that
it's completely different looking than it was yesterday.
Nothing's changed!
Wait!
I mean...
You said yesterday!
Shut up!
It's the-
No I didn't!
*lies* It's the same day!
It's the same day.
And the same time.
Exactly.
AHHH!
Ma boob's coming out!
*wet giggly happy noises*
*laughter*
"Batman just wanted to grab a hand full!" *HONK*
So, uh- for safety because
our fingers were torn to
SHIT!
*lies* TODAY...
We got gloves now because we're smart
T: Yours probably gonna.. explode and kill me
M: Why would it kill you?
T: 'cause it's.. murderous--
M:[mark immattating batman] BATMAN DOESN'T KILL NOBODY
T: *surprised noise bc his tiddies out*
M: BATMAN WOULD NEVER
T: Look I've got-- I've got cleavage
M: BATMAN WOULD NEVER--NEVER KILL ANYBODY WITH CLEAVAGE LIKE THAT
M: HOT DAM
[Tyler laughing exuberantly]
M: MY PUMPKIN'S BEING SQUEEZED BY THE
IRON FIST OF JUSTICE
[BATRUMPET]
I'VE GOT A JUSTICE BONERR
M: Hello :3c
T: Put it back down | M: We've got some cracks forming at the bottom
T: Put it back dOwn!
M: ooooooooh >:3
M: Now I'm getting scared cause
M: At first I was like-- | T: It's gonna explode at any second
M: Yeah it was like 'uhng its never gonna blow'
M: I think they got more brittle
M: I THINK THE JOKER'S PLAYING A JOKER ON THIS
M: Pbleh
M: PTHBTH
M: PTHHPT
M: PFBTHBT
T: [uncomfortably] I'm really glad my mouth wasn't open
M: PTHHHHTBT
M: PBTHFT
T: Yours is reeally...
T: rEAALLY squeezin' in there
M: Is it squeez-- ooh it /is/ squee-- holy shit okay
T: rEALLY squeezin' | M: His face is just
M: hNGWENGWON
M: Oh boy
M: Oh jeez
M: I feel like it's gonna happen soon
T: I saw one-- M: Eugh
T: --break
M: Eegh
M: eegH
*pumpkin faintly ripping*
M: I heard a noise
T: Ohh my god-- M: I heard a noise
T: I hear it
T: The time bomb!
M: OOH T: Ohoh!
Both: *surprised yell followed by shocked and amused laughter*
M: Oh my-- god!
T: That's like a perfect pumpkin bowl!
M: It was de/captitated/
*Tyler giggling*
M: Oh /man!/
T: I thought the whole thing was its head | M: Oh maAn!!
M: Ewuz--okay, then what's it called when they cut your head in
frickin' half??
M: Oh that's justice delivered right there
M: Euoohoohoo grody
M: [laughing] ohh nohoho
M: The poor guy
T: He smells like a pumpkin
*Mark giggling adorably*
M: It's like you go, I go, you go, I go
T: EuaAhelh
T: *womanly voice* oh no!
M: *imitating Tyler* euALelehhg
M: Th- fuck's wrong with you, man?
T: *happily* Everything.
*Tyler laughs and Mark giggles*
*music intensifies*
M: Oh
T: Oh there's definitely a crack right there.
Both: oohwuh
M: Get Chica!
T: Chica!
M: Chica--Put Chica on the table!
M: Chica, shield us! (tyler grabs plush chica)
M: Chica, no! --oH god
*pumpkin ripping loudly*
M: oHGOD
T:EeoOoH!
*re-play of pumpkin exploding*
*laughing in the background*
Chica you're SO brave!!
Oh chica..my gosh.
Did you see the fear in her eyes??
*laughing*(comparing rubber bands)
Yeah that's definitely bigger than this one..
Eeh maybe(?)
That was pretty nice,
but inefficient I'd say..
T: Yeah,
It didn't explode.
Yeah, and that's what we really wanted so..
We have another way to make the pumpkin blow up.
That's it; we're gunna go get it
*bat-iplier outro*
Ok,
So our original plan
was to then cut these open,
pbtput some dry ice in 'em,
glue 'em back together
and then blow them up
we looked it up and ah..
uh, that would qualify as a dry ice
BOMB
and those are illegal in the state of California. *the more you know*
So we are not gonna do that
because we don't wanna be arrested
T: So make sure and check...
M: No, you know what
Just.. Both: Don't do that
M: It's stupid people who
get hurt all the time; don't put it in there
we figured this will be okay because its just pumpkins
but just plain old DON'T DO IT [Anti-Shia-Safety :D]
So that now that's all been done,
we've got a whole assembly of pumpkin here.
Uh mine...
What's mine's name...
What is-I didn't even name mine before
M:  I killed it... | T: I don't think you named yours.
Y-You think you'd name something
before it dies horribly.
T: Yeah... | M: Like, REALLY horribly.
So!
Should we Rock, Paper, Scissors
for the right to sledge first?
It only seems appropriate
I mean, given the circumstance
Let me put this *Tyler giggling*
Alright I'm ready
T: Alright
[MARK WINS]
*Conflicting emotions*
M: Yiss
You don't get to unleash your inner
cavewoman
T: [Dejectedly] First...
M: Alright...
Watch out!
Should I smash mine or should I smash yours?
T: Y-you get first opportunity
M: I'm gonna smash YOURS
T: That's Oh No.
M: His name is Oh No?
T: His name is Oh No.
M: Mine's name is Fred Durst.
T: Fred Durst?
Yea, because he's apparently the person that
M: I stole this hair from
T: Oh!
Twenty One Pilots? Isn't that his name? Fred Durst?
Whatever. Here we go!
NGYAHH!
*giggling, evolves into full blown laughter*
T: Alright!
M: That was oddly satisfying!
So, I'm going for
M: Squidward? Or- what was his name?
T: I forget
M: Doof?
T: Doof.
M: *incredulous* Doof?
T: That's Doof.
M: I think it's Squidward more than-
T: Alright, Doof's gonna get it
huehahahahahahaha
In case you couldn't see at home,
Uhh, not only did Doof get hit
but everything that Doof was- b-  standing on
Well alright then
*laughter from Tyler*
You also collaterally got
uh, uh, Fred Durst here
I think that was the table- his head just-
his head just came off
M: Oh, jeeze!
Well, can you put Fred Durst's head back on, please?
He's not done yet
I- I feel like- and this isn't because
y'know, I'm trying to be malicious or anything,
I feel like I don't want YOU to have to kill
*interrupted by giggle fit*
T: Okay!
T: That's fair, that's fair
M: I feel like if anyone should,
T: Alright
M: I should be the one to bear that burden
T: Yea
M: I'm sorry, little buddy.
*dramatic music*
M: *laughing* You'll always be my little biscuit
M: Up in heaven
T: I'm worried about this one!
*SMASH*
T: OHHH!!!
M: OOOOHHOHOH!
*laughter*
T: Niiice!
Alright, so he needs to stay ON there!
M: He's ali- *dissolves into giggles*
T: For the next hit!
He just wants to help!
M: Oh, jeeze
T: So now it's...
T: Sledge-pumpkin Tim
M: He- he's become
M: stronger than we could've ever imagined
T: I'm going for the one
T: in front of you
M: Oh jeeze, okay!
Here we go
*SMASH*
You keep exPLODING everything!
I'm, like, kinda going generally gentle enough
You just destroy everything you look at!
Like, my goodness!
Good God, man!
M: I guess- I guess we're not reusing this table
T: The table got-
There was a reason I asked you if it was okay!
I- I didn't figure you'd put
huge holes in it!
Alright, if we're gonna go whole hog-
T: I'm moving off screen!
M: Yea, you better wanna move out of the way
*Batman voice*
Batman seeking justice!
Are you the one that killed my parents?
*grunt*
*satisfied sigh*
*beats table into submission* *loudly grunts in happiness*
That felt good
*laughter*
Okay, so that was the, uh
something to do with pumpkin challenge!
Hope you guys enjoyed that. Thanks so much Tyler for joining me!
T: Yea! Thank you for having me.
M: Don't swing it anymore!
M: Swing-
T: EUGHAAH!!
M: Oh jeeze!
Alright, so thank you everybody so much for watching
If you enjoyed this, please let us know down in the comments below
if you've got other Halloween themed
ooooOOooOOOOOooOooooooOOOoooo
*exasperated* One of these days you're gonna "woo" with me
So anyway, thanks again everybody for watching
And as always we'll see YOU
in the next video.
Buh-bye!
Byyye!
[laughter]
We'll put 'im back together again.